hey Luke here with the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and I'm wondering
whether I can ride my bike 200 miles in
one day
I think we should give it a try
[Music]
well it's been a couple years since I've
ridden a bike and I have no idea how
fast or far I can ride so we're gonna go
out and do a little time trial
amazing
just like riding a bike you never forget
how if I'm gonna try to ride 200 miles
in a single day the slowest I could go
is about 10 miles per hour so what I'm
going to do today is just ride for one
hour straight without sprinting and just
kind of see where I'm at
the Speed Racer
this is what 10 miles per hour looks
like I'd have to maintain this for 20
hours it's been exactly one hour and I
averaged 13.36 miles per hour
it's not bad now I gotta go right back
to my car
I know I could do this for several hours
but I don't know if I could do it all
day additionally I burned 650 calories
in just one hour so if I'm not going to
gas out I need to bring and eat about
650 calories per hour while I'm on my
bike
I'm gonna have to think hard about how
I'm gonna do this well I've established
I can ride fast enough now the question
is can I ride long enough so I'm going
to take Tommy on a little bit of a
biking overnight trip here just to kind
of do a Shakedown of my gear and see how
things work out it's gonna be really fun
we're gonna head up to Pennsylvania and
uh and try some stuff out
all right Tom you ready for this
yep all right I'm over this way
[Music]
oh something's not right
oh oh I got a flat
much much later oh
well it's been a little while since me
and Tommy's failed biking trip but I've
got the bike fixed got some nice new
tires on it I got this cell phone case
right here and a little bag for my
batteries and snacks but it's been over
a month and a half since that trip and I
haven't been on my bike at all I had a
horrible lung infection it lasted about
a month and me and the family went to
Portugal for a week and now it's the
beginning of winter and time has gotten
away for me if I'm gonna do this trip I
really gotta do it now so I'm just gonna
try to ride 200 miles without exercising
or practicing at all what could go wrong
the next day all right guys it's the big
day and it's cold we've got frost on the
windshield
I ended up renting a car didn't want to
make my wife do a six hour round trip to
drop me off
that's the end of the easy part
so I'm about three miles away from the
trailhead so I got some writing to do
before I can even start
all right guys here we are at the
beginning of the CNO Canal path it's a
186 mile path that follows the Potomac
River all the way from here in
Cumberland Maryland to Washington DC
[Applause]
we're going to parallel that River all
the way to Washington DC and then passed
on down to Mount Vernon the home of
George Washington if I don't die first
we'll see what happens
foreign
check it out we're on a little Viaduct
the canal had to cross little Creeks
that were coming into the Potomac and
the boats had to sail over those so they
built bridges that went over the stream
and filled those bridges full of water
so the boats could sail over the creeks
and this is an old one that's filled up
with dirt now
I'm glad I got these gravel tires on the
bike now there's a few muddy spots
well guys I got my first 10 miles under
my belt and just about an hour to do it
and the mud and the pack is slowing me
down a bit more than I expected
got one of the lock keeper houses behind
us because the boats were sailing
Upstream the canal was kind of like a
stair step and each step was a lock so
the boats would sail along the canal
into this lock they would shut the gates
flood the lock it would rise it up to
the elevation of the next canal and
they'd open the gates and keep going
cold but there's no bugs it's not hot
and humid and I've seen only two people
so far
[Music]
of this thing where I belong
hey look at me more than what I've
become
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
digging deep
is nice
[Music]
what I thought was gone
sitting in my
place
[Music]
about a quarter mile from the pawpaw
tunnel and apparently it's closed and I
have got to do a mile and a half detour
pushing my bike up and over that little
mountain there
ah
ah
I don't love this detour
but the views nice
I'm tired how are you doing the
construction site is just shutting down
I'm just waiting for the last truck to
come up the road before I can go down
see ya
it's not a mountain
[Music]
so that's the CNO Canal Trail right
there apparently there was a rock slide
in that Canyon and that's why they had
to block off the tunnel
oh it's getting cold
there is a lot of ice on the trail the
sun's setting and the temperature is
just dropping like a rock
so cold out here my fingers are going
numb and it's supposed to get down to 17
degrees Fahrenheit tonight
you know there's a lot of work but I'm
enjoying myself we got a bunch of
audiobooks downloaded on my phone and
I'm just sitting here cruising down the
bike path
middle of the night got the place to
myself
man we've got a lot of trees down over
the path this is like the third one I've
had to go over
just taking a quick snack break got this
chunk of gouda cheese here and a bunch
of fresh dates
this little slab of cheese right here is
820 calories
foreign
I think I've had to cross a dozen of
those logs already
look at this
yeah no possum
hey buddy
oh that's cool I've seen a lot of
wildlife out
all right guys I just hit the 50 mile
mark
oh
well I've done 60 miles so far and it's
about 10 o'clock and I am freezing and I
need to just stop and get some warm food
and get camp set up it is too cold but I
think 60 miles is the most I've ever
traveled on bike in one go so that's
kind of cool some water boiling to make
some dinner and I'm gonna set up my tent
Oh my legs
foreign
it's so cold outside right now that the
butane is frozen and my stove won't work
I'm gonna have to build a fire
dehydrated pasta primavera
it's hot it's got calories I'm sure it's
going to taste amazing
huh
oh yeah spoon's shaking my hands are so
cold
I got a slightly banged up chocolate
brownie and a cup of raspberry hot
chocolate
oh that is so good
I got a liter of boiled water I'm gonna
put that in my sleeping bag to get all
nice and toasty
well I took a bunch of Advil and now I'm
just getting my muddy clothes off I'm
hopping into bed I am exhausted
oh that feels so good with the water
bottle in there I'll see you guys in the
morning because we got a lot of writing
yet to do
oh
so little things in life a hot meal and
a stove that's working I was only able
to fit about a gallon of water in my bag
and I'm mostly done with that so I went
down to the river and filled up this
water filter with some river water and
we're gonna filter out and fill all of
our water bladders and bottles
hot rehydrated biscuits and gravy it's
not the best food in the world but it's
warm food I tell you what that hit the
spot but this entire meal was only 620
calories that's only good for about one
hour of riding
every time I put on these bicycle
helmets I feel like Toad from Mario
Brothers I'm the best I think we're good
the cedo Canal Trail is run by the
national park and they've got these
campsites every three to five miles and
they're free I mean as long as you're
hiking or biking you can just use them
no registration no permits no nothing
and it's really unique in the National
Park system
oh
oh the old haunches are a little sore
we're starting nice and early it's just
barely past sunrise
I think we're gonna put on some serious
miles today if my butt can hold out
just riding my bike through the town of
Hancock here there's lots of little
towns like this
if you're willing to do a little extra
planting you could work it so you'd do
the entire Trail and never have to Camp
you can stay in a hotel and stuff
thank you
the Trail's in much better shape here
I'm going a lot faster not having to
drive through mud and pull my bike over
logs
check it out guys that's a peeveled
whitetail deer those are really rare
Sierra
you see how instead of being Brown he's
like mostly white with little splotches
of brown that's a pigment mutation and
animals get and when you see an animal
with that mutation they're called
Peebles
well I originally started off at the
very lofty goal of doing 200 miles in 24
hours and it's pretty clear at this
point I'm not going to make my goal I've
done about 65 miles and I have four
hours left in my 24 hour period but
that's okay I'm just gonna adjust my
goals a little bit
I want to get a hundred miles
within my 24 hour period
miles to go in four hours but if I can
do that I'm going to be pretty proud of
that I'm a 44 year old dad who is not
trained at all riding a beach cruiser
with three gears if I can do 100 miles
in 24 hours that's not bad but I'd also
like to finish this trip if I could do
the full 200 miles I'd be really proud
of that
did a pretty rigorous hour 20 minutes
just stopping doing a little three
minute walk eat some snacks get back on
my bike
yeah I took it out one of the old locks
every time there's a lock I get to go
downhill
oh check this out
oh this is an Old Mill from 1790. this
is Charles Mill they'd use water power
to turn the big wheel and grind up meal
and Grist 230 years old that's pretty
cool
there's so much history on this Trail
I've already passed dozens of historic
buildings battlefields cemeteries
so this damn's a little bit famous
apparently Stonewall Jackson and his
army attacked this Dam and tried to
destroy it during the Civil War
oh we got rain
I know I'm nerding out on this but I
think it's just amazing that men use
pickaxes and shovels to build bridges
for boats to sail over water and they
did this like 200 years ago
this is an aggressive Pace but I really
want that 100 miles
I just passed a 94 mile marker I'm gonna
have to push Hardware to make that 100
miles I turned off my phone to save
battery so I'm not 100 sure where I am
time wise but I know I'm close but the
trail is really muddy and it's slowing
me down just past mile number 95.
96 miles down
oh dang it looks like I gotta take
another detour oh I wonder how far of a
detour this is going to be
oh I don't like this detour at all this
detour is headed back the way we came
this bike is a beach cruiser it's only
got three gears
it's not meant to go uphill and with
this pack on it is brutal slowing me way
down this detour goes on for miles
come on
oh I take it out
say the Osage orange it's edible fruit
here on the East Coast slice it up and
Grill it it's actually not too bad but I
don't need to carry any more weight
the Osage orange tree is also good for
making traditional bows well the detour
signs just disappeared so I'm using
Google Maps to try to get back to the
casino Canal path all right I think we
found it
foreign
I just saw my first mile marker since we
got back on the trail we're at 99 miles
all right one more mile
oh there's the mile marker I did it
100 miles all right moment of truth now
I gotta pull up my phone and see what
time is
I missed it by 53 minutes those detours
killed me but I biked 100 miles I'm
still proud of that and my phone's fully
charged that's good 100 miles under my
belt I'm halfway through the trip and
despite some setbacks I've had a really
good time and we haven't even seen the
best stuff yet in 20 miles we're gonna
hit Harper's Ferry which is my opinion
the best Civil War site in Virginia they
were going to go past the Potomac Falls
which are these massive waterfalls just
outside of DC we're gonna go through the
heart of the nation's capital we're
going to get to see a lot of the
memorials I'm gonna go past the Pentagon
Arlington Cemetery and go to Mount
Vernon the home of George Washington
you're in the U.S history this has got
to be the coolest bike trip in the
nation and this shocking thing is it's
all free there's no entrance fees no
permits no camping fees and there's
almost nobody on this Trail it's an
absolutely awesome outdoor adventure
just outside the nation's capital
foreign
Bridge
oh that's cool
so much history here I just don't have
enough time to read all the plaques and
stop and explore every building
apparently this dam was built in 1856.
oh
just putting on the miles listening to
another audiobook I'm on my third one
already
I think there's a cave up in those rocks
dang I should have brought my light up
here that cave seems to go back a little
ways
my legs don't like this
well I've done a little over 50 miles
today I've got about 10 before I get to
Harper's Ferry and about 30 before I can
stop for the night
you know my legs are gummy but not all
that sore my bottom hurts a little bit
I'm not gonna lie
his Majesty's drinking
well guys it made it to Harper's Ferry
but it is pouring rain and I'm just
taking shelter under this bridge if it
was a little bit earlier I'd cross the
bridge into Harper's Ferry get myself a
warm meal but I'm just gonna go eat some
cheese and dates and go for it now if
you ever take the Appalachian Trail and
up to hike on this section of the CNO
Canal Trail so I'm actually on the
Appalachian Trail right now
have now done 100 miles and I have been
biking for 15 hours today
I am exhausted
and a little bit nauseous we've got a
camp just four tenths of a mile down the
road
and that's we're going to stay tonight
all right I'm putting this down
I'm completely out of water and a bit
dehydrated up until November they have
water pumps at each one of these
campsites but they shut them down for
the winter so I got to go to the river
and get my own luckily every one of
these campsites are on the shores of the
Potomac so lots of water
I'm gonna fill up my water bottle first
then my camel pack
oh that starts up so much easier today
helps when it's not 17 degrees
Fahrenheit yeah this little MRE tortilla
thing here I'm gonna just stick it in
the pot let it warm up
foreign
[Applause]
they claim this is honey barbecue
wrapped in a tortilla
yeah something like that large food
chicken and rice
so hungry
well it's midnight and I am exhausted
I'm hitting the sack
I'm gonna put up the camera I'll see you
guys in the morning
oh
good morning
oh my goodness I have never slept so
soundly on a campout as I have on these
trips
I done tuckered myself out
it's my final day and I we're gonna do
it we're gonna do it today and I need to
get up and move quickly my wife Becca's
gonna pick me up at Mount Vernon just a
little bit after sunset
so I've got to get there it's uh it's
raining right now and packing up in the
rain stinks
but uh no help in it I just
gotta do it all right
oh
I have had so much trouble with this
butane okay I'm gonna stick my butane in
my coat
I got the spicy Southwest style fajita
breakfast
not my favorite but it's warm and it's
not trail mix and
that's what I need right now
all right time to pack up and get out of
here we've got 51 miles to do today why
I've got about three miles under my belt
all my muscles are starting to warm up
and everything feels pretty good except
my left knee
taking my first scheduled break and I'm
feeling a little better all right back
in the saddle
this is one of the Weirs that lets water
into the canal system from the Potomac
it's what they use to keep the water
levels up
this is one of the historic lock keeper
houses apparently you can reserve them
and stay here if you don't want to camp
that sounds a lot warmer than what I did
this is Great Falls Tavern these locks
are still functioning and in the
summertime they'll flood them and pull a
canal but with the donkey that you can
ride in this is one of the canal boats
but it's winter time so they got it up
on blocks either that or somebody stole
the tires
so this is the Maryland side of Potomac
Falls and this is why they built the
canal to get around all this because
it's winter the water is a little bit
lower than usual this is gonna be really
crazy after a big rainstorm
oh
I only got 10 more miles to the end of
the CNO Canal Trail
whoo
[Applause]
all right guys welcome to DC this is
Fletcher's Cove and the best part is I'm
On Pavement
it is so much easier to pedal on this
pavement I can go like two miles per
hour faster on pavement than I can on
that muddy dirt Trail
I took a little bit of a wrong turn and
I lost the path
when you're getting overtaken by a
Zamboni you know you've made a wrong
turn
this is it this is the very beginning of
the CNO canal
this right here is the very first lock
and this is where the canal boats would
enter to go Upstream all right I have
now completed the CNO Canal Trail now it
took me exactly 49 hours to complete the
entire CNO Canal Trail The Unofficial
record for a bicyclist is 11 hours 30
minutes give or take
that's insane
now right now I've traveled 187 miles so
my journey is not yet through we're
gonna go into DC Through The Monuments
across Memorial Bridge past the Pentagon
Arlington Cemetery and down to Mount
Vernon
Watergate Hotel
right there
that right there is the Lincoln Memorial
it's where Martin Luther King did as I
have a dream speech
there's the Washington Monument in the
U.S Capitol behind it right over there
in the woods is where the Korean War
Memorial is
the Vietnam memorial it's got the names
of every serviceman killed in the
Vietnam War
I am crazy hungry I have got to get
something to eat
I've got three hot dogs
I've got old overpriced hot dogs I'm
sitting on a wet bench on a cold day and
this feels so luxurious
this tastes amazing
amazing
that right there is the entrance to
Arlington Cemetery that house up on the
hill belonged to Robert E Lee when he
left the union to fight for the
Confederacy They confiscated his estate
and used it to bury Union Soldiers
alright guys welcome to Virginia our
fourth state in the trip well third DC
doesn't count
all right this is the Mount Vernon bike
trail
the thing behind me is the Pentagon
where all six branches of the military
have their headquarters
that's Reagan National Airport
so this is Old Town Alexandria Virginia
I think this was the first Confederate
City to follow to the union
well I'm just a few miles away from
Mount Vernon and if my calculations are
correct I just did 200 miles and it took
me only 51 hours
not setting any records but I did 100
miles in a day and I went over 200 miles
so I'm proud of that but we still got a
few more miles until at the end of the
trail
foreign
I made it so uh this is Mount Vernon
this is the estate of George Washington
it's a museum now so you can pay at
admissions fee and get in and there's
all sorts of stuff to see but I don't
ever want to walk again so I'm going to
get a seat and wait for Becca
so guys that's it I've done about 210
miles
oh three miles to get to the CNO Canal
Trailhead 184 miles on the CNO canal and
a little over 20 miles to get from the
end of the CNO Canal Trail to here to
Mount Vernon plus there are a few
detours and roundabouts and other things
and it took me 52 hours I'm tired
I'm really tired
now I just need to sit and wait for my
Becca to come pick me up
I missed you if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
and you'll get notifications thanks for
watching